lucie charlebois ministre délégué à la
réadaptation à la protection de la
jeunesse et à la santé publique madame
charlebois bonsoir à vous ma femme se
doit vous allez bien ça va très bien
vous ça va mieux en tout cas que la
dernière fois qu'on s'est parlé il a eu
il ya eu beaucoup de cris et de pleurs
une crise qui aura duré une dizaine une
semaine vous êtes aperçu quoi le
qu'effectivement il y avait des centres
qui était sous-financée cre était aux
prises avec de réelles difficultés
non monsieur loi je me souviens même
entrevue que je vous ai donné on a
convenu
l'association l'apod elected aujourd'hui
de retravailler ensemble effectivement
on a annoncé 6 millions pour justement
aider au traitement des personnes qui
sont à l'aide sociale alors c'est une
bonne nouvelle et vous avez pu voir les
commentaires des deux associations et
ils sont super content aime moi aussi
parce qu'en bout de ligne autant que moi
on travaille les usagers l'autre affaire
qu'on a convenu c'est qu'on nous allons
travailler à améliorer si je maintiens
la chose de dire quand notre charge peu
moyen ou la totale on a dit qu'on allait
travailler ensemble on va revoir le
processus de certification va travailler
sans femmes et aussi dans les modalités
on pourra certainement être les inclure
un processus de reddition de temps parce
que en bout de ligne quand je parle de 6
millions pour mon argent personnel c'est
l'argent des citoyens du québec qu'ils
payent de l'info alors oui c'est une
bonne nouvelle
et vous savez quoi ça fait longtemps que
je travaille sur ce dossier là depuis la
réforme ont accentué notre héros sam
hamad et moi et évidemment on a
rencontré le président du conseil du
trésor et je suis heureuse de pouvoir
annoncer ça au centre aujourd'hui parce
que pour les centres c'est bien mais
pour les gens qui utilisent des services
est beaucoup c'est bien mieux mais tout
à fait c'est d'ailleurs en leur nom
compose à toutes ces questions là ya dix
jours quand vous a reçu et et madame la
ministre
ce qui veut dire que vous êtes arrivé
vraiment la conclusion que cette réforme
de l'aide sociale avait produit des
effets indésirables sec avait des
centres qui se financer en partie avec
le chèque d'aidé sociale qui n'arrivait
plus à des financiers qui étaient sur le
bord de la faillite
écoutez il ya des constats qui ont été
faits oui mais à toute sorte de constat
comme je vous dis qu'il ya des choses
qu'il faut qu'on réorganise avec les
associations votre meilleur partenariat
premier constat c'est ont fait le
constat qu'il faut travailler ensemble
c'est assez clair deuxième constat c'est
comme je vous disais quand on parle
d'uniformisation de la tarification je
pense que c'est là on reprend s'asseoir
et discuter sur quelque chose qui peut
avoir du bon sens mais au delà tout ça
je pense que tout le monde attend le
bien-être de toutes les personnes qui
vont dans les centres d'intervention et
moi aujourd'hui le communiste
responsable la réadaptation
je suis très très fier de remettre ses
conclusions le savez la réforme que fait
mon collègue à l'emploi solidarité
sociale le chèque que lui remet au
centre d'intervention c'est pour le
logement et le gîte et le couvert
lui le traitement ça relève pas de lui
honnêtement ça relève du ministère de la
santé
mais il fallait prendre le temps de tout
regard de son peu pour régler les choses
en deux minutes parce que sinon je
ferais mais magique comme ça très bien
mais le même temps tellement facile
le montant que vous réinvesti le 6
millions $ qui est bienvenu
effectivement vers l'entente surmontant
le corps est l'investissement
en fait je m'excuse de vous couper je
pas habitués au duplex est ce que j'ai
le goût de vous dire c'est pas un
réinvestissement parce que moi je pars
emploi s'adapter sociale au ministère de
la santé c'est un investissement qui
provient de nos fonds c'est complètement
différent très les gens sont contents
parce que quand ils reconnaissent que
c'est chez nous que ça devrait se
traiter ces choses là ok il ya 1,6
million dollar qui sera ajouté ceci
millions de dollars correspond grosso
modo aux économies qui étaient faites
dans cette réforme des aides sociales
l'échec était coupé à 200 dollars quand
ces gens là allaient dans des centres
n'est ce pas mais vous savez quoi la
réforme de l'aide sociale va se
poursuivre sartre paul
la seule chose qu est ce qu on dit les
personnes qui sont à l'aide sociale qui
vont chercher qui font des intérêts qui
vont dans les centres d'intervention
indépendance pourront maintenant les
centres de dépendance pourront avoir une
somme pour les aider pour leur donner
les soins appropriés
c'est ça qu'on dit c'est que les
enveloppes sont placés au bon endroit
et là on va revoir la règle son compte
et tout et tout mais on va pouvoir
travailler avec les associations
c'est pas au 15e étage du ministère
qu'on fait ce que vous pourrez demander
aux gens qui sont dans les associations
il le fait que je travaillais depuis
longtemps sur ce dossier là mais il
fallait arriver avec la bonne solution
encore il faut revenir avec les
modalités vous savez quoi on voit les
rencontrer pour vous travaillez en forme
pour trouver les meilleures solutions
mais le ils savent qu'il ya 6 millions
qui est réservé pour les personnes qui
vont chercher des des traitements dans
ces centres d'accord mais je social le 6
millions c'est à peu près le même
montant que vous économisez avec cette
réforme ce point est là bien précis de
l'aide sociale du des coupures pour le
jack ainsi sur cette base non mais je
vous demande c'est ce que ces mêmes
montants
même si le même montant ça le pit
différence harper plus se répète moi se
passe je ne suis pas parti de la base de
calcul de ce que si tu es en fois sa
liberté sociale
je suis parti de la base de calcul de
comment on peut faire pour l'améliorer
sans non seulement décembre de départ de
deux traitements mais déjà je vous le
dis là on avait plusieurs scénarios sur
la table on est arrivé avec celui là il
y en avait un autre qu'on donnait
directement l'usagé il n'avait donc y en
a plein de scénarios
on n'est pas les lois en italie bon
travail avec les maisons
c'est le montant rien à voir vous le dis
le jeu insiste là c'est juste qu'on est
arrivé à cette conclusion le avec la
forme de calcul qu'on a fait d'accord et
reviennent avec un poste adapté et les
gens qui pourrait vous poser la question
madame la ministre
pourquoi parce que les gens vous avait
déjà rencontré les gens de malartic et
les gens de l'association avait envoyé
une lettre au premier ministre et c'est
pourquoi il a fallu que ça aille jusque
là cette crise là avant qu'on règle
justement
vous savez je travaillais comme je vous
le dis bien avant cela les gens de
l'association des deux associations
pourront vous le confirmer mais si
c'était magique
mon travail c'est le fun parce que on
pourrait régler mal 20 premiers 24
heures c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne malheureusement et comme vous
savez on vient de sortir d'une période
qui est s'appelle de noël et la nouvelle
année
dans ce temps-là il ya comme un deux
semaines de flottement alors moi j'ai
peur j'ai jamais jamais jamais arrêté de
travailler sur soi douce est là et les
gens dont je vous parle pourront vous
confirmer ce que j'arrange très bien
aimé la ric pour qu'on soit clair avec
les gens qui nous écoutent
il est trop tard c'est terminé mais la
rigueur ben je vous entendu dire
cependant je ne sais pas d'où ça sort
que j'ai dit tantôt au direct ce que je
disais tantôt des élèves dans une autre
entrevue c'est que non les cas
particuliers tout comme mais la ligue
devront être examinés individuellement
parce que mellal et quand une histoire
on verra comment on peut les aider
ailleurs mais le ils savent qu'ils
peuvent avoir ils peuvent compter sur
l'argent qui correspond pour les gens
qui sont à l'aide sociale maintenant les
difficultés qu'ils avaient à 20 ben là
on verra avec madame beaucoup puis je
vais pas étaler sur la place publique à
moins qu'elles désirent le faire
elle-même elle l'a fait pendant les
ouvre on va lui parler à madame bongo
pour voir ce qu'il pourra voir une
ouverture de mails avec madame la
ministre merci merci au revoir
bonne soirée